you're old community pal yes Donald
Glover is do you want to be helped
Donald failure yes he's done well
nothing's working is a musical career
and being on Star Wars has not helped
have you do you have a good relationship
with him you guys must have gotten along
on no I haven't spoke to him in for it
no uh we text a little bit but he is the
busiest person alive and I hear so when
we we're on community together
I had my son Eddie would he would come
to set and Eddie doesn't like to say at
that point he didn't want to say hi to
anyone and I would kind of force him so
I would say he said I didn't be like
that say how I was like say hi to Donald
and to hit in his rebellion he'd always
go hi stupid and anyone always crack up
Donald and but then we ran into him
outside of a bakery
right near here and Eddie psalm from a
distance as he's walking towards he's
like hi stupid doesn't recognize him now
a couple of years no age my he's 13 now
he's like the same size got long hair so
it looked like this little homeless man
screaming at him and there's like people
are walking up to Donald and they're
crying and they're so happy to see him
and there's my son like you're stupid
huh you still stupid oh that's gonna go
over well and then Donald gave him a
Tesla it was really that's nice
you